WE'LL BE CHECKING OUT WITH YOU
AS IT CONTINUES TO MOVE BEHIND
THE SCENES.
I WANT TO GO OUT FRONT NOW TO
ONE OF THE KEY REPUBLICAN
HOLDOUTS WHO SWITCHED HIS VOTE
TO MCCARTHY TODAY.
CONGRESSMAN DAN BISHOP.
HE VOTED FOR MCCARTHY ON THE
12TH AND 13TH BALLOT.
BUT, OBVIOUSLY UP UNTIL THAT
POINT, HAD NOT DONE SO.
SO, CONGRESSMAN, I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
AND YOU KNOW A LOT ABOUT WHAT
IS HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
SO I DO WANT TO GET TO WHY YOU
SWITCH YOUR VOTES IN JUST A
MOMENT.
BUT, FIRST.
THE BOTTOM LINE, HERE
CONGRESSMAN.
WILL THAT MCCARTHY HAVE THE
VOTES TO BECOME SPEAKER TONIGHT?
>> I ANTICIPATE THAT HE, WILL
AARON.
I'VE BEEN AMONG 20 WHO HAVE --
IT WAS DESCRIBED ON YOUR AIR IN
OTHER PLACES AS, CHAOS AND
DYSFUNCTION.
I'VE BEEN IN THE COURSE OF FOUR
DAYS --
WE'VE COMPLETED WORK THAT'S
GONE ON FOR SIX MONTHS ARE
BETTER TO COME TO AN AGREEMENT
WITH KEVIN MCCARTHY THAT IS
HISTORIC.
THAT WILL, AS ONE MEMBER PERSON
TOLD ME TODAY, I HAVE VERY
HIGHLY PLACED PERSON, IT'S
TRANSFORMATIONAL.
I BELIEVE THAT WITH OUR VOTES
AND THE ONES THAT ARE
CONTINUING TO BE WORKED, ON
KEVIN WILL BECOME SPEAKER.
AND WILL IMMEDIATELY PROCEED TO
ADOPT THE RULES BACK IN THAT
WILL BEGIN THE PROCESS OF --
RESTORING THE MOTION TO VACATE
THE CHAIRS.
TONGANS --
WE'RE UNDOING NANCY PELOSI
CHANGED THE HOUSE AND STARTING
RIGHT AWAY.
>> CONGRESSMAN, WHEN YOU SAY
THE ONES ARE STILL WORKING ON,
WHAT IS THE STRATEGY RIGHT NOW?
ARE THERE GOING TO BE THREE OF
THE SIX REMAINING THAT VOTE
PRESENTS?
ARE YOU TRYING TO GET ANYBODY
TO VOTE FOR MCCARTHY?
WHAT IS THE ACTUAL MATH THAT
GETS YOU TO A SPEAKER --
KEVIN MCCARTHY TONIGHT?
WELL, YOU KNOW,
>> THOSE ARE THE TASKS OF
KEVIN'S PEOPLE AND THE --
TEAM AND SO FORTH.
THOSE OF US WHO ARE FEW DAYS
AGO, AS I SAID --
IT WAS NEVER CONCEIVE THAT 20
MEMBERS, BY HAVING THE COURAGE
TO STEP FORWARD AND INSIST WE
ATTENDED SOME VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUES, COULD LAY THE
FOUNDATION OF WHAT WE ARE GOING
TO DO.
WHAT WE ARE DOING RIGHT NOW
TONIGHT AS ALL THAT IS
HAPPENING THAT YOU DESCRIBE
ABOUT TRYING TO GET INTO THE
CORRAL, THE LAST FEW HOLDOUTS,
WE ARE LOCKING DOWN AND MAKING
SURE THAT THE AGREEMENT WE HAVE
REACHED IS FULLY DOCUMENTED AND
BEGINS TO BE IMPLEMENTED ON
TIME.
THERE'S A LOT HAPPENING.
THIS IS NOT CHAOS AND
DYSFUNCTION.
IT'S A HISTORICAL AND --
EXERCISE THAT ALL AMERICAN
SHOULD BE PROUD OF.
>> DAYS WENT BY.
YOU CHANGE OR VOTE ON THE 12TH
BALLOT TODAY.
SO, ON TUESDAY --
'S FRIDAY NIGHT, OBVIOUSLY.
ON TUESDAY, YOU SAID, AND I
QUOTE YOU, KEVIN MCCARTHY IS
NOT THE RIGHT CANDIDATE TO BE
SPEAKER.
SO IN THESE NEGOTIATIONS, CAN
YOU TELL ME EXPLICITLY WHAT IT
WAS THAT GOT ADDED --
WHAT HE CONCEDED THAT GOT YOU
TO CHANGE OUR MIND?
>> IT WOULD BE MISLEADING TO
SAY IT'S A SINGLE THING.
WE'VE GOT IMPORTANT FISCAL
CONSTRAINTS SO THAT WE WILL GET
ABOUT THE TASK OF CONTROLLING
THE EVER EXPLODING FEDERAL
BUDGET AND DEFICIT.
WE HAVE, TO ME --
FOR SOMEONE ON THE JUDICIAL
COMMITTEE THAT'S CONCERNED
ABOUT, THIS WE HAVE A SELECT
SUBCOMMITTEE AND JUDICIARY TO
LOOK INTO THE WEAPONIZATION OF
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AGAINST
AMERICAN CITIZENS AND THEIR
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHTS.
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
RULES CHANGES.
WE CALL IT JERMAINE THIS AND
SINGLE PURPOSE AMONG THEM.
WHICH WILL HELP US TO AVOID
HAVING THESE MASSIVE BILLS LIKE
WE JUST ARE RAN THROUGH RIGHT
BEFORE CHRISTMAS WITH LITTLE
OPPORTUNITY TO READ --
DECIDED BY A HANDFUL OF PEOPLE
IN THE BACK ROOM.
AND THEN WE'RE GOING TO HAVE
CONSERVATIVES DISTRIBUTED ON
IMPORTANT COMMITTEE THROUGHOUT
CONGRESS.
SO THIS --
IT'S A REALLY, REMARKABLE
ACCOMPLISHMENT.
AND I'M APPRECIATIVE TO LEADER
MCCARTHY, SOON TO BE SPEAKER
MCCARTHY,
WHERE THESE DIRECT NEGOTIATIONS?
YOU HAD, YOU AND HIM?
>> UNDERSTAND, THEY BEGAN WITH
RULES CHANGES.
BACK IN JULY OR AUGUST.
WE COULDN'T GET ANY
CONVERSATION FOR A LONG TIME.
YES, KEVIN AND I HAVE PARTIALLY
HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS.
HE'S HAD MANY, MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH OTHERS AS
WELL.
I WOULD PARTICULARLY GIVE
CREDIT TO CHIP, SCOTT PERRY OF
PENNSYLVANIA, THE CHAIRMAN OF
THE HOUSE FREEDOM CAUCUS, CHIP
ROY OF TEXAS, I HAVE NEVER SEEN
MEMBERS WORK MORE EFFECTIVELY,
DILIGENTLY, AND WITH GREAT
DISCIPLINE TO ACHIEVE THIS FOR
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
OUT FRONT NOW, MARGARET JOHN,
KAREN, AND SCOTT.
OKAY.
YOU AIN'T GOT WERE VERY EAGER
FOR HIM TO LAY OUT THE MATH.
HE DIDN'T EXACTLY DO THAT.
HE IS SITTING WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE OF THAT 20 THAT YOU
HAVE.
HE SEEMED SURE.
>> A LOT OF OPTIMISM COMING OUT
OF ALL WINGS OF THE PARTY AFTER
SOME CONVERSATIONS BACK AND
FORTH WITH SOME PEOPLE WHO ARE
NOT REALLY HOUSE FREEDOM CAUCUS
TYPES BUT OTHER MIDDLE OF THE
ROAD TYPES.
THEY ALSO THE SEEM TO THINK
IT'S GOING TO HAPPEN TONIGHT.
OPTIMISM FROM ALL PARTS OF THE
GOP.
WE WILL SEE WHAT THE RULES
PACKAGE LOOKS LIKE TONIGHT.
WHAT THAT PORTENDS FOR
GOVERNING IN THE FUTURE.
FOR THE REPUBLICANS WHO WERE
NERVOUS ALL WEEK THAT THIS
CONFERENCE WAS NOT GOING TO BE
ABLE TO PULL ITSELF TOGETHER,
THIS IS A GOOD GAIN.
MCCARTHY DID WHAT HE HAD TO DO
TO GET THERE.
WHAT DID HE HAVE TO GIVE AWAY?
WE WILL FIND OUT LATER.
EARLIER TODAY, WE ALL THOUGHT
WE WOULD BE HERE TALKING ABOUT
NEXT WEEK.
THE FACT HE GOT IT DONE TONIGHT,
I THINK HE DESERVES, HE AND HIS
TEAM DESERVE CREDIT FOR PUTTING
THIS DEAL IS QUICKLY --
GIVEN WHERE WE WERE 24 HOURS
AGO.
>> WE DON'T KNOW THE DETAILS
ABOUT WHAT WAS GIVEN UP,
ALTHOUGH YOU COULD HEAR THAT
FROM --
KEY WORDS COMING UP.
THOSE COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS,
THE SUBCOMMITTEES, THOSE THINGS
REALLY MATTER.
IT'S CLEAR THAT MATTER TO HIM.
>> DEFINITELY GOING TO BE IN
THE DETAILS, AS THEY SAY.
IRONICALLY, IT'S GOING TO --
ONE OF THOSE DETAILS MAYBE A
72-HOUR WAITING PERIOD BEFORE
VOTING ON BILLS, THEY WON'T DO
THAT TONIGHT BEFORE APPROVING
THAT FIRST --
>> 72 SECONDS.
>> I THINK WE WILL ALL AGREE
PART OF WHAT LIKELY HELPS OUT,
I DON'T DISAGREE, I WILL GIVE
YOU GUYS SOME CREDIT HERE,
HOWEVER, LET'S NOT FORGET,
THERE IS ALWAYS --
CONGRESS IS ALWAYS ACTING MORE
STRICTLY WITH A PRESSURE OF A
DEADLINE.
THE FACT THAT WE HAVE ALSO BEEN
HEARING MEMBERS ARE TIRED, THEY
WANT TO GO HOME IT'S, THE
WEEKEND, IT'S FRIDAY, THAT
HELPED PUSH THE CASE AND THE
PRESSURE ALONG WITH THE REALITY
OF THE MATH.
>> THE DEADLINE WAS JANUARY 6TH.
WHEN KEVIN MCCARTHY GOT THE
NOMINATION, HE KNEW HE WAS
GOING TO GET TO 18.
--
THEY TRIED TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS OVER THE SUMMER
ON SOME OF THESE ISSUES.
THEY DIDN'T GET ANYWHERE.
AND THIS TORTUOUS PROCESS IS
DYSFUNCTIONAL.
MCCARTHY DESERVES CREDIT.
IF HE GETS THE BALL DOWN THE
FIELD, I THINK IT MAY VERY WELL
BE.
LET'S REALITY CHECK EVERY
SECOND.
WHY IS IT A DESIRE FOR LONG
WEEKEND WHEN IT'S CONGRESS THAT
SHOULD HAVE DONE IN THE FIRST
PLACE FASTER?
THE SECOND THING IS SOME OF
THESE THINGS WE BELIEVE TO BE
IN THE DEAL, TERM LIMITS,
BORDER SECURITY, HAVING MORE
TIME TO READ BILLS, THAT STUFF
THAT MANY INDEPENDENT VOTERS
WILL SAY, THIS IS --
>> WE GOT HELD UP FOR THAT?
THAT'S COMMON SENSE.
>> WHY WAS THIS SUCH A BIG DEAL?
WHAT ELSE IS OUT THERE THAT'S
GOING TO LEAD TO REAL
DYSFUNCTION OF >> THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
THERE WERE 20 HOLDOUTS.
THERE WAS A LOT MADE OF THESE
20 HOLDOUTS.
WHY ARE THEY BEING INTRANSIGENT?
IT TURNS OUT THERE ARE MAYBE
SIX WHO ARE INTRANSIGENT.
THERE ARE LIKE 14 WHO
ABSOLUTELY HAVE SUBSTANTIVE
POLICY PRIORITIES THAT IT
LOOKED LIKE.
WE HAVE A GOOD SENSE OF WHO
THEY ARE.
IT'S ABOUT RULES, COMMITTEE,
SUBSTANTIVE BILLS BEING BROUGHT
TO THE FLOOR, CHAIRMAN SHIPS,
IT'S ABOUT BUDGETARY CONCERNS,
BALANCED BUDGET.
WHAT I WOULD SUGGEST IS THAT
CHIP ROY WHO YOU CAN THINK OF
HIM AS THE TED CRUZ OF THE
HOUSE.
HE WAS TED CRUZ'S CHIEF OF
STAFF.
HE IS A PRINCIPAL FISCAL
CONSERVATIVE FREEDOM CAUCUS
GUY.
HE WAS ABLE TO DELIVER 14 VOTES
THAT ACTUALLY CAUSED THIS
BREAK.
IT TOOK THIS TO GET KEVIN
MCCARTHY TO PAY ATTENTION TO
THESE SUBSTANTIVE POLICY
CONCERNS.
COULD THEY HAVE HAD THESE
CONVERSATIONS A MONTH AGO?
>> YES.
>> BUT THEY DIDN'T.
>> ONE OF THE DETAILS I'M
LOOKING FOR TONIGHT, BECAUSE
THERE IS A LOT OF CHATTER ABOUT
THIS IS WHAT AGREEMENTS WERE
MADE AS RELATES TO DEFENSE
SPENDING.
THEY DID THE OMNIBUS.
THERE WAS A MASSIVE INCREASE IN
DEFENSE SPENDING.
THERE HAVE BEEN RUMORS ABOUT
WHETHER THERE WILL BE MANDATED
CUTS IN DEFENSE SPENDING, OR A
FREEZE.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT THE TRUTH IS
HERE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF DEFENSE
HAWKS IN THIS REPUBLICAN
CONFERENCE WHO WOULD LIKE TO
SEE MORE DEFENSE SPENDING.
>> AGAIN, COMMON WISDOM IS THAT
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY WAS PRO
DEFENSE.
YOU'RE GOING TO SAY THEY WILL
HAVE THIS GROUP?
>> THERE'S ALSO A GROUP THAT
DOESN'T LIKE THE MONEY.
IF THAT PUSH AND PULL IS ONE OF
THE SUBSTANTIVE POLICY DEBATES.
I'M LOOKING FOR THE DETAIL.
>> CAN WE EMPHASIZE THE MATH
HERE.
I UNDERSTAND THE CONFIDENCE.
THE MATH IS NOT OBVIOUS.
WE ARE NOT CLEAR WHAT IT WILL
LOOK LIKE.
YOU NEED TO GET THROUGH PEOPLE
VOTING PRESIDENT OF THAT'S.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE YOU GET
THREE.
RIGHT?
DO THEY HAVE A DEMOCRAT OUT?
WE DON'T KNOW.
THERE ARE VARIOUS WAYS TO GET
THIS.
>> THEY ARE TRYING TO FINESSE
THIS AT THE FINAL MOMENT.
>> WE CAN SEE HOW IT GOES, HERE
YOU GO.
WE CAN'T SEE THOSE.
>> WE ARE HEARING, I WILL SAY,
FROM THE CALM PERSPECTIVE, A
LOT OF CONFIDENCE.
CLEARLY THEY THINK THEY HAVE
GOT IT AND THEY THINK BY
GETTING OUT THERE AND GETTING
ON THE AIRWAVES AND SAYING WE
HAVE GOT IT THAT MAY PERHAPS
KEEP IT IN PLACE.
--
>> IT'S BETTER THAN SOUNDING
DOUBTFUL AT THIS JUNCTURE.
THERE WILL BE CONSERVATIVES ON
EVERY COMMITTEE.
EVERY REPUBLICAN IN THE
CONFERENCE IS THAT --
RADICALS HAVE BEEN HOLDING THIS
OUT.
WHAT I SEE NOW, ALL THE
NEWFOUND ENTHUSIASM ABOUT
REDUCING THE DEBT, WHERE WAS
THAT FOCUS WHEN DONALD TRUMP
WAS PRESIDENT AND INCREASED BY
SEVEN TRILLION DOLLARS?
IT WOULD BE NICE IF THEY MEANT
IT WHEN THERE WAS SOMEONE OTHER
THAN A DEMOCRAT.
>> SOME OF THE SPENDING WAS
COVID RELATED.
>> SOME OF IT WAS.
THAT'S FAIR.
BUT SOME OF IT.
HE WAS A BIG GOVERNMENT DEBT
GUY.
LET'S NOT FORGET THAT.
>> SCOTT, BACK TO THIS, BAGS,
GOOD, BOEBERT, CRANE, LET'S
FOCUS ON ROSENDALE AND CRANE,
YOU GET THEM TO VOTE